south carolina's city is stun it stunned
after a gunman ambushed least killing
one and wounding six others the four
police officers from Florence South
Carolina and three sheriff's deputies
were shot outside a house while serving
a search warrant police officer Terrence
caraway died in the gunfire
he had just celebrated 30 years on the
force a suspect is in custody but has
not been identified
David beg know is near the scene in
Florence about a hundred miles north of
Charleston David good morning John good
morning the suspect perched like a
sniper opened fire on three deputies
initially leaving them wounded in the
front yard then four officers responding
as backup were shot as well there was a
moment of desperation with officials who
tried to figure out how do we get in to
rescue these men without risking another
life this morning the only officer who's
been identified is the man who died
hard and difficult Baker of overcome
with grief Major Mike none of the
Florence County Sheriff's Office
recounted the tragedy that unfolded as
his deputies approached the home
approximately 4:00 p.m. suspect inside
the residence opened fire on the
investigators three of our deputies were
shot police officers from the city of
Florence responded as backup and four of
them were shot fire was being shot all
over the way the suspect was positioned
his view of fire was several hundred
yards and the officers couldn't get to
the ones is down police were forced to
use a bulletproof truck to rescue the
wounded officers the suspect allegedly
held children hostage while barricading
himself inside the home the standoff
lasted for about two hours and then the
suspect surrendered today we lost a good
friend of mine Florence police chief
Allen Heidler was unable to fight back
tears as he described the fallen police
officer Terrence caraway who served on
the force for more than 30 years Heidler
called him and the rest of the wounded
officers family pray for these officers
and their speedy recovery pray for the
family who lost the bravest police
officer that I have ever known
the CBS affiliated Myrtle Beach South
Carolina WB TWU reports that a 20 year
old man inside the home was also shot we
don't know how he's doing this morning
and Gail it's kind of tricky we don't
know a lot we don't know how that man is
doing we don't know what the suspects
name is and we do not know the
conditions of the other officers who
were shot we're hoping to get some kind
of update later today
something tells me David beg no you will
have those answers by the end of the day
thank you very much we appreciate you
joining us this morning